from Marvel Studios down the hall
neighbors and joss whedon little brother
comes the franchise that isn't as
popular as the movies and isn't as
critically acclaimed as the Netflix
shows but darn it it's getting better I
mean that's what I hear anyway I stopped
watching every through season one agents
of shield enter the world of the
strategic homeland intervention
enforcement and logistics division
someone really wanted our initials to
stop shield for half a season until
Winter Soldier pulled the rug out from
under it shield Hydra it all goes now
get ready for a show about the agents of
shield doing whatever it takes to help
Marvel sell their movies we call
ourselves in humans listen they're doing
the best they can okay
Marvel literally blew up their premise
Avengers fans assembled to see your
favorite superheroes names get dropped
Thor's Thor Captain America Captain
America who's gonna start Stark Iron Man
Barton Romanoff Romanoff Romanoff The
Avengers The Adventures of the Avengers
Hydra World War two Captain America
while you spend your time with a guy
named Phil and his awkward walk on
military were hired by one of the
largest gem brokers in the world you
thought he was dead but now he's back
because the show needs a lead and Sam
Jackson was too expensive but agent
Coulson's not the only non Avenger on
board
watch as he assembles a crack team of
the best non movie characters available
like Skye aka Daisy
aka quake a hacker slash inhuman who's
the closest thing this show has to an
actual superhero Melinda may a lady spy
with a dark past who totally isn't Black
Widow these quirky British scientist
sevens who are completely
interchangeable until they sent one in
his space and gave the other one brain
damage grant Ward who starts out good
then turns bad then turns kind of
then turns bad again and is now a weird
zombie demon alien hybrid thing and this
revolving door of black characters you
know this isn't the walking dead right
you're allowed to have more than one at
a time but the agents of shield aren't
alone
they're joined by some of Marvel's most
prestigious be less characters like Nick
Fury two times Peggy Carter in a
flashback Maria hill that's cool I guess
Thor's lady friend Captain America's
drinking buddies agents
sit sit good this random Asgardian
played by the guy from ghostbusters 2
and the way that's it come on Mikey you
can't get Hemsworth there for like five
minutes on his lunch break share your
freakin toys man so gear up for the show
that Marvel fans criticized for not
living up to the Marvel movies despite
the fact that it has 1/10 of the budget
while having to stretch its storytelling
across a 22-episode network TV season
while also awkwardly shoehorning tie-ins
from every new Marvel movie you know it
would be nice if for once thorn is
people sent down the god of cleaning up
after yourself without being able to use
any of the important Marvel movie
characters firm when you really think
about it it's kind of surprising that
it's even as good as it is starring dead
man walking
Natasha Romanov Buffy dry white toast
definitely not mutants Tahiti told me
the same to Tahiti
it's a magical place to you it's a
magical place
Tahiti
Tahiti it's a magical place how is the
heating it sucked
look texture you're still protecting
your secrets we need to protect him from
this I did it for you to protect you
there's no left to protect it it was to
protect our team from a monster it was
to protect her protocol protocols
protocol protocol protocol Fargo
critical crap protocol crap protocol
protocols ridiculous Holograms
no let's just upload the specs to HQ
good idea and slowly turning acting
reacting and and voting silently
law-and-order
super Victims Unit
whatever Colson we all know what a real
super agent looks like you will not me I
would totally watch this crossover hey
screen junkies want to see our real take
on agents of shield then check out the
first episode of our new original series
interns of field to find out about
superheroes assistants assistants it's
twice as funny as agents of shield and
half of that is on purpose come on guys
we work really hard on it and really
appreciate you watching it 100 pushups
100 situps 100 squats then a
10-kilometer run every single day I've
got you for three minutes three minutes
of playtime squashing the guten crotch
the bat is dead Barry consider this
mercy I love chimichangas a famous lie
in a famous movie by a famous person